citizens of the reject Nation it is a momentous
occasion John Aaron Alexander in a video together
to throw down on some Street Fighter 1994. how
you feeling bud did you are you excited as I am
I am more excited than I could possibly imagine
I'm ready to hadouken some fools oh yeah at the
screen speaking of hadouken leave a hadouken on
that like button as well do some kind of crazy
ass combo to the Subscribe and notification
Bell to get notified when the next John and
Aaron massive collaboration event happens also
gotta say a big thank you to the folks over
at prepper they do a killer job chopping
up these edits every week on these movie
highlights some love over to them and as well
if you want to see all the stuff that doesn't
get cut out of the reaction if you want the
complete Street Fighter experience come on
over to patreon.com the real rejects we got
tons of movies and shows where you can sync
up and watch along with your own copy join us
for the full experience it's a lot of fun and
uh Hey without further Ado let's drop two
coins in the machine and uh and and and
finish him is is Moral Combat I don't know let's
watch him do it baby that's right I like that yeah
[Music] yes it's like a Tommy Wiseau production
we gotta get both versions of the bumper yes
although it is nice to see the OG it's the
classic or you know it's been so long one
of the many Classics it's a good one it's
a crisp one I also like the little airplane
one I would hope they'd play all of them just
like as uh we spent money on these all right
we went to school with this kid
Simon callow is in this this is
it's gonna be the whole reaction just
us flipping out does every famous
person who's ever existed in this movie
defeating the heavily of General M bison
Raul Julia Raul Julian 63 hostage remains
is that what Zen GIF you came from across
the world to fight me Soldier now is your
chance square up let's do this let's go I
like his puffy suit based on Street Fighter
2 specifically okay damn that was very quick
instantaneous yes your turn now this is the
beginner training mode where you learn the
controls we thank you sir please oh these
dudes have potato chips for an x man those
Colonel Giles Van Dam's Colonel Gile okay
look at yourself on television you're
six enough a [__] so look at this
you have three days if my 20 billion dollars are
not delivered by then the hostages will die and
the world will hold you responsible oh Carlos
Blanca so you are Guile's friend take him to
the laboratory is he gonna get like transformed
this is the thing is like because because Street
Fighter and Mortal Kombat characters will start
to swim together so I'm trying to really keep
myself on track here they blend they're both
products of the 90s and Tekken he doesn't like
women does he no he doesn't like journalists equal
opportunity dislike it's a great delivery on that
oh oh oh oh what's this dude's name
the theme song we'd be wrong yeah [Applause]
Vega that's his name that guy's got an awesome
look I I totally knew that good evening
sir God quite a party did anyone tell
you there's a curfew you've been shot a loose
city no one tells me anything it must be hard
to get around my men have already unloaded the
truck and brought the weapons here of course I
like my games live and In Living Color oh In
Living Color let's do this where's homie the
clown let's get it let's get into some fights oh
streets and then that would make ten Jim Carrey
oh [Laughter] [Music]
I got the real guns now it's a kind of cool intro
for Ryu and Ken with a Nerf a literal Nerf element
my signs Twisted to serve for version instead
of Peace after I've crushed my enemies we'll
see about getting you published that should
chew you up yeah call Penguin press [Music]
whoa oh no I see everything merely
educational software why does he
find it disturbing because unlike you he's not
psychology he's not an immoral like sociopath
the brain has become a killing machine my
loyal scientists will start on his body
yes oh my God anabolic plasma DNA
mutagens DNA mutagens vodka drink
it's like that stuff you get like a haunted
house [Laughter] where are you yeah Burger
yeah like the first official Street Fighter fight
sorry I talked you into all this I'm sorry I
listened I'm sorry bud it's weird they're they're
not as like hyper cooled up as I would expect it
yeah there's like regular smeggular guys over here
he looks like he took a break from like his his
bank job to come kick some ass I'm on my 30 guys
I gotta get back to the uh the accounting office
oh he's handsome dang it's like every
anime where a guy wears a mask [Music]
love this majestic music what's
the aluminum soil ass sword nah
man it's just that sharp and shiny I
love it aluminum foil sword [Music]
good I don't need no sword
of course this movie is a tease
give us some street fights baby yes did I
do that you roll under arrest [Laughter]
that's awesome always say for certain is his
base is hidden somewhere here the river Delta
Region yes okay all right this movie is
going so hard how did he get in there
get him out of there any
other new business [Laughter]
he's the coolest dude on Earth [Laughter]
hands down oh he's a Death Eater oh [__]
transition dude that was a
good transition I liked it
that's the cover of a romance novel right there
100 yeah it's missing Fabio
and like you had to complete
they didn't watch back the footage
when they recorded this yeah that's
good enough come on make it
sound cool and we're good
do Awolnation just providing all the assets to
the military All Nations let's go Sail [Laughter]
no wonder they're all boats it makes sense
the AWOL Nation Refugee Center they're on
some boats it's like exactly their logo I wonder
if anybody realized that like the the A and the N
are combined but otherwise it's like the same but
they knew what they were doing they were like we
love Street Fighter that much are you the same as
Sagat and bison or am I right and you're different
I love this man's acting and his voice I love all
the acting but his voice yeah Guile's voice is
supreme this is an over guile I own this city I'm
the Ripple man and you're out of business [Music]
the two best characters don't fight guys
flashing back to like Elementary School it's
crazy how much he looks like him foreign
I gotta say I like the the camo colors I
don't know what you're blending into but
sitting back there it's like it is
fun the way they're making so many
characters like Collide in these crazy situations
yes
they wouldn't kill him off he's got to
come back like does he does he get like
modded out or something oh smart chunley bison
and that the new a at first order of business
Colonel guy oh Say It Ain't So that's great news
General congratulations [Laughter] congratulations
I love this guy why do they still call me a
warlord and mad I'm so chill I'm the nicest
guy is to create the perfect genetic Soldier not
for power not for evil but for good yeah like
like when they made the atomic bomb until the
very planet is in the loving grip of the packs
is that so wrong I love this it's clear
go yes get those Melinda May skills going
let's get down to business
oh that's even better you beat me you beat me
another homing device rolling with the Homing
that guy oh put it back oh my he's alive
awesome that was give you an interview when I was
alive no way I'm gonna do it when I'm dead what
Hollywood guy over here how long have you been
laying there I don't want a story about bison
when I'm this close I started when I
was fresh out the womb been holding this
microphone down since day one basic
blacks not really you Prison Breaks
okay yes yes do not flip let's go for Chase
do some Jason Bourne [__] what a screw
up what I'm sorry oh oh said the guy
no he's getting introspective he's like
what a screw-up we really screwed that
up I feel sorry for us right now God all
right [Music] Cirque du so bison [Music]
very good
Capcom I see what you did there well done I
like that this universe Capcom just makes caps
[Applause] but how
nice [Applause]
this has been a glow up yeah this is the first
scene not to not to slight the Marty McFly and
Doc Brown look they were going for earlier but
uh this is good oh significant upgrade oh yeah
I'm looking at them both like okay okay [Applause]
that's a very video game thing this way haha let's
see the color of your money I don't know what to
make of that these guys [Music] Shredder masks
bison bucks bison bucks every bison dollar
will be worth five British pounds change
rate the bank of England will set to one side
kidnap their Queen fail-proof plan you ready
no not the place in books
your admin Honda the Sumo from Hawaii
this conclave is over yes get the claw
you will die for this insults I got
10 minutes things can't get worse what happens
right before things gone it got worse what who
would have saw that coming because there
are enemy spies everywhere Among Us general
and this may be my final broadcast but
if it is that we have not died in vain
but we will have ends introduction to this
part of the world oh no Bisons the God all
your weapons of death are going to be blown the
Sky High good timing on opening that door there
yes is that an insert that they
can see I love that this movie
the approach to Dynamics is like change
the channel that'll stop it this guy's
eyebrow acting is amazing really though
it's like every few minutes they'll go
let's take it back down to like an eight
and then let's go right back up to 15.
whoa he has to stay ready whoa
the technology of east and west
while the government scorned me the
corporations adored me that is our bar
they will talk or they will die
preferably both [Laughter] take
the uh to my Chambers we have decided to grant
her a private interview uh this way attention
dehydrate yourself these guys are good guys
like us oh snap I didn't realize they were
doing an undercover thing that I'm glad he said
that the only chance is an assault with a small
amphibious Force the main force will come from
the north while a single vessel equipped with
the latest in stealth technology yeah a single
boat against everything he's got would have
to be out of his mind that ADR is that is the
greatest at line read I've ever heard I wonder
if it was even the same guy right [Music] that's
a very like Temple of Doom sort of Sheen around
it when you're out here and spices shut up oh yeah
let's go Pulp Fiction he likes it what the [__]
it's like I trained for this this is my
exact thing man this is just Saturday for me
the failed trombone has sounded yeah next Yankee
the tuba maybe you ought to lie down first
damn not not to the boxer man he's gonna knock
your block off later yep damn lashing buddy keep
on crying out I'm Sumo brother my body could
be in one place my mind another bars bars it's
actually a very kind of neat little Sumo inside
there now you look like bison Troopers yep you
got him final forms let's go you're instructed
to call off the assault we are prepared to pay
the ransom demand what will prevent him from
taking more hostages next month and asking for
50 billion all the money in the world deliver
these instructions to your troops then consider
yourself relieved of your command oh you're fired
so Moral Combat with this guy the war is canceled
we can all go home bison is getting paid off for
his crimes and our friends who have died here
will have died whose only concern is
we wrap this up freedom and justice
they get packed up but I love these facial
expressions we can all go home I mean this
is a very diverse Army very true yeah you know
like men and women of color Street Fighter is
woke and I'm going to kick that son of a [__]
bison's ass so hard yes that the next bison
wannabe is gonna feel it yes no who wants to
go home and who wants to go with me [Applause]
oh my God yeah
what's up God we are just go we are
literally just going right to war no
prep time or anything it's awesome this
this movie has like little kid and then
energy in the best way the best possible
way yeah War gathered your small out
[Music]
oh Slave Leia way to make them leather like
that my father was the village Magister
[Music]
bye it's my love making hat
that's my sexy cap you had him shot as you
ran away no I'm sorry don't you feel that
I don't remember any of it damn so you can't
hardly hold me responsible if I don't remember
it didn't happen it was the most important
day of your life but for me it was Tuesday
I mean he's aware of his own perspective
I guess I gotta give him that is that the
line it was Tuesday yeah this shit's normal
to me you guys had one job and I don't think
oh no if it isn't our little
buddy's double crosses
I think he said he could lead us
outside with us outside lead us
outside I found Partners who
hated you as much as I did
John Wayne Gacy fainting I said poker
the clown John Wayne bison [Laughter]
turn the sexy on since you entered this country
you never even threw a single punch I
know women and you are harmless wow bro
go Andrew Tate exactly what I wanted
you to think yes it's time yes
there it is getting the kicks
let's go
there's a mortal a street damn it was a
Street Fighter for you there there's a
Tekken yeah there's a bloody Roar Capcom versus
SNK how many can you name comment below [Music]
oh no room gas room gas pesky room gas [Laughter]
damn you room gas Cavani Honda you're
our only hope I love all his stuff
this is great this is my favorite movie I love
this so much it's wonderful now if we could just
get a solid romance going it'll have literally
everything a movie needs attention all boards
stand by at attack Vector Alpha I'll take
out the enemy radar cap ice and [Laughter]
race you watch the whole movie right now family
who took this boat to West Coast Customs whether
they give the boat to exhibit oh my God look
at him what is he becoming they're pumping him
oh is he hulking out the making of green yeah ah
[Music]
oh memories
who's that couple getting married love Martin
Luther King this is not a racist monster they're
teaching him critical race Theory right now
they switched over to the woke cerebral program
she may be a hideous monster
but at least he's tolerant yeah
it's very well adjusted very intersexual
intersectional philosophy that guy
unsuccessful just like saw five
damn it approaching Bisons out
of radar perimeter prepare for
stealth mode online who's ready
they're gonna see us so we'll put down our
visors that'll protect us and it's going down
we're going down down and earlier round sugar
we're killing them bison look at that camo
it's actually not a an entirely bad effect
Sono detectors and filter all inputs
detected they're jamming us you
didn't account for sonar in the water
[Music]
our defenses are locked onto you
oh your ass is six months overdue
and it's mine get that ass
get it his death was designed
to ingratiate his spies with you
if you didn't see that did you jeez you're a honey
you will witness firsthand the power
that you spurned damn oh [__]
is that an actual Street Fighter
console looks like a game cabinet
oh [Music]
reverse of what this game would be if you were
actually playing it that's
a that's amazing [Music]
it's a street fighter baby [Laughter]
what are you doing nothing [Applause]
it's weird is he turning him into Martin
Luther King I guess so he's got all the
rage of like Humanity's breadth of Destruction
plus all of its greatest tolerant philosophies
monster Luther King yeah
Blanca Luther King [Music]
bro damn not the kidneys I like that it that it
really took a long time to load right
seems very the tech in this breathing
you know he's not gonna be smart your brain's the
first thing to go with oxygen deprivation [Music]
Hulk [Music] save him save
him from washed up Super Mario
I will break you
uh by an elephant yo
dude those were strategic
elephants yeah a pachyderm unit
oh whoa oh snap oh right
through the spooky spider web
being deposited the 20 billion in my Swiss bank
what hell no that'll be a firm hell no on
that one hell no I repeat hell no we set
electronic and visual markers ETA Landing Zone 12
minutes yeah it's got the tank top I'll be ready
I'm alive you're the coolest guy ever you'll
be alive you've already thwarted death once
you can do it again
clear I just love how customer service that voice
sounds for how Sinister the words
actually are hostage pit hostage pit
search Ron Jeremy's dead body you might find
something you might find something you're not
a little not ready for you'll always
find something you're not ready for it
oh no no
steam Charlie it's me I'm your friend William
Will i Am
oh what's that voice it's cool to
get to know William and not just
guile you know who who's the man
himself right that's good personal
oh no he's gonna put him out of his misery
dude no he's gotta have a street fight
no no you have no right yes yes damn
straight Dr Frankenstein Stephanie use him
good shot you shall be killed by a
wild beast s oh no I did what I could
to preserve his mind his mind retains the
capacity for good yes and for evil as well
he's true neutral the real monsters upstairs
he expects to see his creation surprise him
that's a face
oh surprise [__] yes get the kick looks so
Overjoyed by that [Music] oh my God damn all
right I got dark real quick yeah sorry
guys but this is for your own protection
please kill guyohawk right now
oh no of course
[Music]
yeah yeah get it get him get the hostages free and
I'll get you two first class tickets home okay go
go yes now you're getting serious we
got fan service to do my man yay [Music]
let's go yeah give us a street fight
[Applause] through the floor the cerebral
programming we're expected in here
[Music] no cute little boy
oh yeah get some Cooks
[Music] so this level is like playing some kind
of big open multiplayer and a first person shooter
[Music]
then defeat is a possibility oh no we
shall face it together DJ what do you
mean together I don't know about all
that is that is the best that's right
that's my boy right best performance
beat in the whole movie oh my God
have fun with that upstairs
before we don't oh now you're coming with me
or not just kiss already before this place
blows up we can find something worthwhile no
thanks I already found something worthwhile
I fight pro bono I don't understand I
don't understand no boys can't break up
now the boys need to be back in town
yeah oh they will be they will be
let's go let's go baby
good swinging Shia [Music] is not gonna shoot him
don't worry you survived it was everybody's there
don't even need to say it uh that's fun
still no sign of bison you really thought he was
the [__] for a second come out from behind the
curtain wizard let's see how pure your combat
really is yeah are you man enough to fight
with me come on you can't oh yes I can if I'm not
upside in 15 minutes evacuate Without Me Love is
American flag tattoo right damn wow he's towering
over them next I'll make you a dead one yeah
oh look at that the guns I don't
even gonna try and replicate the
welcome to the gun show hey [Music]
sure could yeah yeah oh my Godzilla
yeah I edited this meme together with some
Godzilla audio clips what do you think sir
[Music]
no no [Music] you'll have to do
better than that okay okay [Music]
he's ringing his Bell he's bringing his belt
[Music] oh yeah
oh it makes it like you're gonna punch him
you're gonna get a split kick in here come on
okay yeah now we're cooking yeah
I got a little wind-up yeah buddy
oh yeah that's nice let's go flip
kicks someone's button mashing in here
let's go Circle down
oh you know it's funny the lightning bolts are the
most dated looking effect in this movie [Laughter]
they really are when he gets so ripped he's not
just rip the entire film I'm okay I'm just half
dead and all that yeah the water's reinforcements
are still hitting the beachhead Live Support
oh
things are happening but we still haven't found
the hostages yet seemed like a monster
or something oh yeah yeah he's back
unlimited power hey do it [Laughter]
my mama didn't raise no fool baby damn straight
damn straight I should have stayed at
Microsoft oh so Windows XP was your
fault or Millennium Edition that's the one he
designed his Millennium Edition since 1994.
you could have saved us from that he was a little
preoccupied where are you where are you going
oh my God are we really doing the the science
experience this is awesome get Spotlight yeah
this locker room looks like a laser tag
place or like a haunted house oh yes oh
no got him with the kitty claws Vega where were
we oh lucky number seven what happened to the
Purity combat this is merely superconductor
electromagnetism surely you've heard of it
it levitates my desk where I ride the saddle of
the world oh they're talking about harnessing
this technology again now wow how timely
oh look at them kicks I never had a pair
of light up shoes I don't think maybe maybe
a little I want those not that sweet though
[Music] I wonder if they use any of the video
game sound effects or some cheating there's two
against one come here prepare to fight a madman
and instead you found a god oh I am a god [Music]
reunited and it feels so good
yes yes let's go do it [Music]
dang not bad nice
[Music]
I know people are strong is when
they break the training equipment
[Music] yes cook his face cook him
he's gonna have a seven sunburn yeah
[Music] that was a funny flip
that's what I'm talking about
I want some of these paintings
tell me man he's palpes now there's a
face he was making though was so good
wow you know big respect to Raul
Julia yeah this oh that kick nice
got that spinning Van Damme kick wow
please hurry oh tears of joy
sorry man can't play no more it's been fun
dude I wish we could do it again [Music]
never felt so validated by someone
before our boss is the enemy our
freedom and peace these people have come
from all over the world to stop him if
[Music]
invite you sir
Max opportunity
oh no if only you could sue after this I
almost feel bad for him [Music] then give buddy
my man
evacuated we helped yeah we held it up too you
know we contributed we have to go this whole
place is gonna go up I got you back my friend
don't like this oh I missed your tone for my
part in this evil if good men do nothing that is
evil enough damn thoughtful guy gotta say didn't
he have hair before he did was that like a two
pair to get burned off what's going on there
oh I mean I assume the scientists know something
we don't but it seems like the both
of them are just gonna die yeah right
hold on YouTube very good very
good this is stupid I'm done I'm
done with all this crime stuff want
this gun anymore I even like bison
[Music]
he's got his accurate costume little shorts
in his his beef posture right severance pay
wow look at that gash oh no I think it is he
told us to leave we did the right thing well
it still feels pretty wrong to me you said it
Kyle hey yeah Lieutenant make need a vacation
I wish I knew oh on the way out yeah
yes of course of course somebody was
chopping onions for the rations sir
no longer mid straight to awesome
bison box how about that interview
sure
oh flirty oh my don't jeopardize
your journalistic integrity all right
[Music]
yes
oh my God I love that I guess
she had to turn around got this
flash page that was awesome God was
this was this whole movie oh wow God
wow that was fun that was a lot of fun it's
time once again for the good morning Shadow
Pop Quiz do you know what it says on the
bottom of Coke bottles and bison's army oh
there you go I was gonna say we're gonna
have to like pull up the list of of all the
of all the characters just in case we missed oh
yeah somebody because this is like jam-packed full
of yeah obviously legit but I thought that was him
damn I I should have called it out because he's
only in like a couple scenes early I think when
uh I think it's like when Ryu and Ken walk into
that fight club at first and uh he's like one of
the goons and he's always like you know like right
or left side of frame like prominent like first
goon just out of focus like you know who is that
um he's a prolific stunt and martial arts actor
like he's he's been in a lot of stuff like you've
seen him in a lot of stuff I know him best I think
from uh Gross Point Blank he plays Like A Silent
Assassin and he has this whole like extended
sort of comedic action scene in that that like
features him directly but okay but yeah he's been
in a bunch of other martial arts joints and stuff
but uh but yeah my man what did you think of the
Cinematic masterpiece of Street Fighter [Laughter]
I thought it was fun uh oh I sense a butt coming
on me right now no but no no butt like uh like
guys trying to take he didn't walk out with his
severed butter that's right nah I mean it was it
was fun you know I don't I don't know a ton about
Street Fighter but I can I recognize like the
visual accuracy to some of the characters I think
that was fun I imagine a lot of Street Fighter
fans in the 90s probably are have hold a lot of
nostalgia for this film but yeah I thought it was
like a good time like the soundtrack I thought it
was corny like the AGR the ADR was like a little
rough sometimes but I don't know it kind of added
to the charm of the movie you know yeah it it is
definitely one of those movies that has a sort of
uh it's weird it has that so bad it's good quality
we're like yeah it's it's moving at this crazy
Breakneck pace and like every set of characters
we focus on or cut to is in their own movie and
every one of them is like hyper saturated and
cranked up to 11 it's corny and campy and Goofy
but at the same time for what this is and it's
also reminiscent of a lot of other movies like
it's weird like there's a good amount of like
Indiana Jones kind of stuff in here when you're
going like the further you get into uh bison's
Lair and all that stuff right and certainly
various like military movies and like buddy cop
Hong Kong movies and stuff um but the one thing
I kept coming back to is like I don't know if
this was like a a huge budget movie or like a big
Blockbuster of a deal at the time I imagine it had
to at least have been an event but I was like you
know this movie doesn't seem like it's hurting for
a budget like it it's got a lot of production
values it's got a huge cast and as cheesy as
everybody is like everybody for the most part
showed up like this has that bingo card I guess
of like I think you know you've raouled Julia as
the sort of centerpiece of like this guy is the
classically trained actor who is giving it his all
he's committed and even though this is silly he's
really commanding my attention right now and then
you have you know action guy Jean-Claude Van Damme
with the wacky dub and then you've got like you
know the the Buddies uh in Ryu and Ken and then
uh and then you've got like your one random uh
strange stiff delivery ADR Soldier like you know
it's just you've got so many things you've got
like a Frankenstein and a monster story happening
there's random bits of like philosophy philosophy
musing they don't have to put in like it's yeah
it's so kitchen sinky and it's so I think I said
it earlier on like it has that little kid like and
then this happened and then this happened and
this character comes in that this character um
right but yeah it was Mark Ellis that's right man
he helped do some of those background projections
for the visual effects team you know we're all
the way back in 94. little baby Mark Ellis again
Lee started like the second she was born doing a
press for the birth to 20. Ice Cube I don't know
he wrote the street fighter song what the hell
dude look out man Public Enemy yeah with all the
you gotta get the soundtrack now right no totally
gotta buy it but no yeah to build off of what
you're saying hello cool Jay this is a stacked
yeah OST wow far side damn geez everybody this
is like the soundtrack of the 90s uh so to build
up what you were saying yeah man I felt that even
though you saw like different degrees in acting
Styles within this film you know within this
movie you see that like Raul Julia he's like he's
Hamming it up but but he's also like believable in
the role that he's playing or that was really cool
it felt like everybody knew the movie that they
were in yeah and they embraced that fact which
is something I appreciated you know and they were
they were all there for the vibe they knew this
was like this is like this is fun it was supposed
to be a fun movie in 1994 built off of the Street
Fighter property and yeah I think you know because
of that it really shows on screen the the energy
and and effort they tried to put into it I do
agree that the is the effects were uh pretty good
for the time I imagine like people would be really
impressed with watching it at the time like wow
post credit scenes yo did this in the 90s oh snap
what one solar battery online
oh no perhaps is coming back
M bison returned somehow
domination replay rewind oh my God
and I love that his hand pops out like Carrie oh
my God I I oh see that's the thing is what I loved
about this experience is like yeah it's silly and
stuff like that I do think like the production
values are pretty decent given how kind of goofy
a lot of the movie is but the thing is like this
it entered a territory it's like so bad it's
good kind of just has to happen right and this
movie obviously is is I think you you hit it on
the head it seems like they approached this with
fun but also commitment so it's like in some
ways it does just fall into being a little bit
so bad it's good because I don't know it is the
90s and it's like the first time we're figuring
this out and so it is a little silly but at the
same time there are moments where I'm like you
know that's actually kind of neat or like oh this
actually looks pretty good in terms of how they've
brought you know all the different elements of
the production design together and I do think
it could have used there's a lot of action and
there's a lot of military actions to certainly
so like it's it's fun in that way too and there's
certainly a fair amount of martial arts and wire
work and all that I could have maybe used a little
bit more of a show-stopping hand-to-hand fight of
some kind yeah I feel like yeah yeah that's the
thing it's like there's a good amount of editing
and there's a good amount of coverage on that
stuff where I feel like man if they had just
gone that little extra step of like it's funny
I think it's for the better that they have that
moment where uh Ken sees them on screen and it
looks like a literal Street Fighter level and
you're like oh are they gonna do it like the game
I like that they set that up and didn't have to do
it uh because it's like we get it however I did
think that that presented an opportunity to like
here's okay here's a One-Shot fight so that we
can just watch the courtroom just the opening of
it and just like have the fight start that way and
then go into like the regular fight would you like
sure the whole fight or keep it there I mean like
they'd put a lot of the Bison guile fight in a um
you know side by side sort of thing or on you know
yeah sort of a profile perspective and uh and that
kind of hark into the game but yeah just something
that that accentuated the choreography I think
would have been a nice kind of element to step up
for this because again I don't think the action's
bad or flat but it was like oh man if they had
really like got somebody used to shooting like you
know Hong Kong martial arts style stuff to come
in and you know really make these moments sing
that much louder I mean like this this movie has
it's called status but I feel like it could have
like a slightly stronger one if that element had
been just a little bit more you know I don't know
saturated or just you know engaged yeah I could on
the craftsmanship tip I can agree with that yeah
I will say I like the music yeah I thought
the soundtrack was really cool I mean that's
the thing is everything like again there's like
lots of fun and wacky elements and the score too
is definitely going all over the place and there
are times where things remind you of um of uh like
there are things that reminded me of like this
sounds like a classical piece this sounds like the
planets or something like that and then you know
you have other things that are a little bit more
like video game oriented and then like whenever
you cut to E Honda there's like a Hawaiian lap
steel playing for some reason like it's cheeky
but at the same time again it feels like in the
in the best way because everything's kind of like
that and it seems like a very intentional unified
Choice despite how kind of everywhere the movie is
and it's like every character you cut to you could
kind of just have a movie just about them true
and so like it is this weird thing of like you
know like you know Chun Li shows back up or there
are moments where like certain people will be off
screen for a while or like right Ryu and Kenny
you're like oh like I you've probably been on an
adventure this whole time what we've been doing
Zangief sumo fight like that was off screen for
a while yeah you're like oh I forgot they're even
fighting yeah I think that's what made me think of
it but uh but let's review our street fighters
here because yeah Colonel guile chunley uh Ken
Kenneth Masters he just can Tammy was uh oh that
was Kylie Minogue okay nice not bad okay we got
Ryu uh let's see General balrog was in there all
right um um let's see okay Charlie Blanca that was
cool I like the Blanca stuff it would have been
nice to have like yeah maybe like one more actual
beat with him but yeah yeah thunderhawks he's uh
utilize him a little more Vegas got dollism there
you go that one that one dude and then uh yeah DJ
and I wish he got to fight oh yeah that was that
was kind of a bummer I was like this guy is such a
I I like that they gave him like a fun personality
um sorry I think it's a general ball rug but that
would be Gerard balrog that's the boxer right
um it's like I know so many yeah there you go
okay I know so many Street Fighter characters
from growing up and from playing the arcades and
stuff like that but yeah it's like there's certain
ones where you know as the gallery grows and I
think they said this is based on Street Fighter
2. so it's like there's so many names and stuff
that I would recognize and then you know there's
so many other like Mortal Kombat names that you
record like this this was not that this is like
a direct representation of the games but I was
like okay so the vibe is like Mortal Kombat is
more Supernatural and horror influence whereas
like Street Fighter is more like military with
a slight kind of sci-fi kiss on it yeah you know
it's sort of how this this representation made it
feel yeah that's that's the thing I got from it
I'm not like a huge Street Fighter person I don't
know like a ton I played like very very casual
yeah I could play some Marvel vs Capcom so like
I recognize some of these guys but yeah I thought
it was it was really cool you know it made me want
to see a modern one to see like what they would do
now with this property yeah yeah absolutely well I
mean you know we've got the Legend of Chun-Li
film that we could always check out someday
um and it's air can contrast and it is kind of
fun and interesting to see what characters got
changed because yeah it's like you have Dr dollism
Who you know I think is a like a game fighter and
so that character has been like completely changed
and I feel like they took so much of his aesthetic
and just made it to set dressings and stuff like
that but uh but yeah cool to see early uh mignon
see Jean-Claude Van Damme and two it's like you
have so many people who have become prolific and
and so many other people who are like from more
like mid-level stuff like it's it's interesting
who you know Grew From This versus who you know
maybe siphoned off into more specifically martial
arts based stuff or like B-movie stuffer or off I
like you know kind of outside the main Hollywood
bubble sort of stuff I only recognize like a
handful of people this is a 35 million dollar
budget so I think it's money I mean it made a
hundred million worldwide so I mean like enough
like I don't know I'm sure the business was a bit
different back then and you probably maybe didn't
need to make quite as much as you do now but but
yeah I don't know this seems like it certainly had
all the resources to be as much movie as it needed
to be without hurting for it and uh and while yeah
every fighting game is going to have some kind
of weirdness and translation I still thought that
for for the for the you know amount of like fun
and bounciness it had it never bored me it never
you know got on my nerves even though certain
characters get changed and you know maybe watered
down as a result still you feel like you've got
a substantial amount of game characters and stuff
like that I'm sure there are many more like uh
uh you know different fight level Landscapes that
you know probably flew past me just in this this
current uh moment because it's been a while since
I would have played a Street Fighter game but uh
but yeah you have this story where at least even
if you're not getting a bunch of one-on-one fights
you get a lot of opportunities for different
characters both uh you know Street Fighters
and shadowy warriors to fight one another to
fall on different sides of the line and then to I
thought they did a fun game of teasing where it's
like oh yeah we're about to throw down and then
oh [__] Colonel guy will burst through the wall
now there's like a whole other thing happening and
and yeah like even if it's not like a one-to-one
translation of the source material this this
felt like about as good as this could go in a
fun kind of cheeky sort of way for the time you
know for my money like I I had such a blaster
watching this yeah yeah I mean I don't know like
I said I don't know a ton about uh Street Fighter
as a property but I I was watching it taking
it for what it was you know I've I feel like
maybe I would have been more like that's not how
it is if I was like a huge fan of the property
maybe maybe people who are huge fans are like that
maybe they're not maybe they're just grateful for
the fact that they have a Street Fighter movie to
represent what they like on the big screen uh but
yeah I think you know a lot of the sentiments you
shared I thought were uh of similar mind to myself
you know just like I like the just the different
Dynamics we got to explore and all of the
yeah the fact that they made you like wait for the
fights you know and just you know what I'd like to
see in like more cool fights in the beginning
sure but like when you get to see them towards
the end it's awesome so yeah I would say I had a
good time with it you know not being too critical
no alcohol required no alcohol required well all
right team what'd you guys think of the Street
Fighter motion picture did you grow up on this
is this a Blasphemous take on your favorite video
game or is this an underrated gem you let us know
down below also comment with your favorite Street
Fighter character in fact before we get out of
here who's your favorite character in the movie
Zangief baby thank you with those eyebrows I mean
I kind of gotta meet you there I mean as much as I
love DJ and as much as you know shouts out to to
Damian Chapa holding it down as Ken uh yeah Zen
geef boy he he really understood the assignment
and he was just like I don't know whenever we
cut to you just just eyes browse that's all we
need you never don't know what he's thinking
yeah guys comment below leave us your thoughts
and before we get out of here let's do a patreon
pandemic Jones we nominate you as the next DLC
character in the street fighter franchise what
does pandemic Jones's look for for his character
oh pandemic Jones he wears a big old hazmat suit
yes I like it yeah and uh Indiana Jones hat and
Indiana Jones hat you know yeah he's one of those
characters he's one of those characters who you
never actually see there like inner form but yeah
he's like a combination of like a swashbuckling
Adventurer but also a Hazmat you know uh uh you
know Wrangler guy yeah yeah I like it you know
he has his whip but he also has like little
masks he like he'll throw some stuff at you he
can throw it yeah dangerous viral chemicals at
you yeah totally dude pandemic Jones I love this
I cannot wait to play as you and then fight one
of our other patrons whoever we decide on the next
fighting type of movie that's who you're gonna be
versing so keep an eye out now you gotta watch
all this shout out to know but anyway we love
you stay pledged um because you know as they
say pay to play but no we appreciate your love
and generosity every month my dude and we will
catch you next time much love and uh and yeah